[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time for
some more science [ __ ] with the arrival
of the Breaking Bad movie El Camino the
long anticipated sequel sees a return to
the world of the hit TV show Breaking
Bad after many of us were left wondering
what happened to Jesse and the show's
final few moments over six years ago
throughout this video I'm gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the new film and its
ending there's gonna be heavy heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything runed about the movie then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you stick around until the end
of the video for my review and without
the way huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into a breakdown of El
Camino the movie opens with a flashback
of Jesse talking to Mike before the
latter's death in which they discuss
what freedoms they will soon have once
they're out of the game and where they
should go
the scene is pivotal to the film and it
instantly sets up the aesthetic that
Jesse will do whatever he can to get way
to the life that he worked so hard for
it's the real driving force pun intended
of this road movie and due to the
sentimentality laced with in the opening
you as a viewer are really rootin for
the character to get away this story
then picks up immediately after the
events of the final episode of Breaking
Bad season 5 Felina with Jesse just
escaping Jack in his cruise lab having
been saved by Walt hunted by the police
who were hot on his tail right from the
off there's a real intense feeling
throughout as we watched Jesse using all
means necessary to escape a long arm of
the law the film is laced with close
calls seemingly endless police come boys
and there are a few narrow escapes by
the skinny Pete of his teeth luckily
Jesse drives better than a blind guy
with no legs and even though they're hot
on his tail he still manages to stay one
step ahead of them along the time now
the big question on everybody's lips in
the lead-up to this is did while really
die in the finale or is he still alive
though the prior trailer answered this
definitively there's still been a lot of
speculation as to whether he will
returned for the special or not alchemy
no once more confirms that yes
Heisenberg is indeed dead though it
takes a long time getting to it not
dropping a full report until we're half
an hour in Cranston does return in a
flashback in the latter part of the
movie which I'll get into later but he
doesn't come back in some big blaze of
glory while some fans may be
disappointed by this in my opinion it
actually raises the stakes a lot more as
we realize that jesse is the only person
that we can read for and thus his story
becomes even more engaging jesse suffers
from PTSD due to his time in captivity
and from the off Aaron Paul absolutely
nails the portrayal of a fractured man
on the brink of collapse that must keep
it together it perfectly laces
flashbacks throughout the narrative that
flash out just how torturous life was
for Pinkman whilst Walt was living it up
in the wilderness well sort of his
appearances by the aforementioned Mike
Jesse's parents fat Damon and many more
that remind you of the slave labor that
Jesse was forced into at the hands of
his captors
it also reintroduces characters such as
the junkyard dealer and skinny peon
badger making it feel like this is a
world we never left and it's awesome
seeing them return it's a real trip down
memory lane but at its heart is Jesse a
broken man just wanting to get away we
get the sense that he is desperate to
survive going from a man that refuses to
even point the gun at Todd to then
aiming to at a policeman in order to get
one more minute of freedom they turn out
to be criminals too and they split the
money three ways where we also learn
that they work for Candis welding which
was the company that added to Jesse's
prison and was also complicit in his
torture
Jesse eventually makes it to the vacuum
guy who as we learned from the original
series is capable of moving high-risk
targets across state lines
however he refuses Jesse flat-out due to
the character owing him for the no show
last time and being short by $1,800 for
a new wipe Pinkman is forced to go back
to his heavily surveilled parents in
order to get gun so he can go to Kandi's
and get the money after asking nicely
fails to work Jesse goes into a fast
draw with the owner shooting him from
his pocket and killing the other
criminal that was pretending to be a
policeman Jesse takes their money
destroys the company responsible for us
two
chair and we get off flashback of Walter
which is probably the big money shot
that everyone has been waiting for
it's a real heart to heart in which the
promise that all of Walt's wrongdoing
wasn't for nothing and that his family
will get all of the money that they're
owed once he's gone it also hints
towards Jesse's future with Walt
suggesting that he goes into business
marketing after college as he has the
skills that know how to do it even
though Walt and Jesse had a rocky
relationship which is exemplified by
this conversation we do get the feeling
that while really did have his best
interests at heart and that he wanted
him to do well once everything was over
with this reminder and now the money
jesse is able to go to the vacuum guy
and be transported up north to Alaska
which was paid lip-service to in the
opening conversation with Mike and Jesse
with the new name Driscoll Jesse can
finally start a new life
he gives the vacuum guy a letter bra
Cantillo who many will remember was the
son of Jesse's girlfriend that was
killed in season five and Jesse
remembers Jane his other girlfriend who
died and remembers the promise that they
had to run away and start a new life
together
Jane stated that similar to Jesse she
had gone where the universe took her her
entire life and that it's better to make
those decisions for yourself and we end
with Jesse on the road heading out to
start something new it's a great ending
that perfectly mirrors the end of
Jesse's escape from captivity at the end
of season five and lets us know that
he's finally finally free but what did I
think of the film well personally I
absolutely loved there and now I was
initially worried that this would ruin
the perfect finale for the show it
developed it in several ways that made
it a gripping watch El Camino is
unbelievably tense at some points and
the show is laced with so much paranoia
that it makes it an edge of you see
watch at several instances the policeman
scene was nail-biting throughout and
each actor here really brings their a
game Jesse Plemons who plays Todd in the
film really knocks it out of the park
and watching him almost treat Jesse like
a pet was innocently discussing how he
murdered people that learn too much
really flashes out his character in an
awesome way he would steal every scene
that he's in if it wasn't for the
excellent portrayal of Jesse once more
by Aaron Paul this is the best acting
that I've seen
from him and he pretty much goes through
every emotion with these perfectly
conveying a man who is completely on the
edge it's outstanding to watch and I
really cannot stress enough just how
much he delivers in this role
absolutely knocking out the park at
times with his performance El Camino is
an amazing watch that while slow paced
up points feels very intentional in
order to build atmosphere and tension
making it breathtaking to watch in full
4k with Dolby vision and the movie looks
absolutely incredible
and it's actually worth the upgrade if
you have the right setup at home the use
of light darkness and detail all come
together to paint this as a grim world
with moments of hope throughout the
seemingly never-ending bleakness though
I was hesitant at returning to this
world I'm so glad that Vince Gilligan
and Netflix decided to take one more
shot at this and it's a devastating was
also empowering end for one of TV's most
memorable characters this had the
potential to either end up like Felina
or be more like the fly episode and
thankfully it's the former that the film
lands in El Camino had me absolutely
gripped from the beginning to end and
this is by far the one to watch this
weekend this is the perfect wrap-up
again to these characters and Vince
Gilligan has once more added to his
universe all while to creating something
that's fresh new and engaging it's
absolutely required viewing and if you
aren't caught up with a show or haven't
even watched an episode yet then you
need to go back and work through it in
order to get to this El Camino is
brilliant and that's why it gets a nine
out of ten I've actually spoken to a
handful of people about this film and a
lot of them kind of found it
disappointing but I just thought that
the atmosphere acting and overall
tension have really really made it
something special now a lot of people
might not like the slow pace and have
wanted a lot more action scenes but this
is a purely character driven piece that
massively captured my interest so yeah
if you're a fan of Jesse then you're
gonna find a lot to like here
now obviously I'd love to you your
thoughts on El Camino and if you enjoyed
it as much as I did or if you will let
down by the film comment below and let
me know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of this weekend's other
big release Gemini man which
be linked at the end I go over
everything that you need to know about
the film so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to come chat to me on Twitter
then make sure you follow me at
Definition YT and if you want to join my
discord and keep up to date with all our
latest releases and just chat about
movies TV shows comic books and games
then make sure you click the link in the
description we've got an awesome
community and hopefully I see you over
there after this also just wanna let you
know that we're currently giving away a
free copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
El Camino in the comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from them to ever get
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]